may I ask the guys a couple of Rapid
Fire questions just to give you a
breather to really listen to the sound
of what they're saying number one your
parents are dying they need a hundred
thousand dollars worth of surgery and
you don't have the money for it the
tabloids say we'll give you a hundred
thousand dollars if you tell us what's
going on with Drew do you turn in Drew
and save your parents life of course
life you do turn and Drew and uh of
course also my parents are listening
right now so okay
number two what do you do it's a hundred
grand to save your parents life no I
find another way to do it I I I I'm as
transparent with Drew as possible and I
say this is what's happening and I'm
going to find it another way number
three what do you do yeah absolutely but
I will lie to the tabloids about what's
up with Drew so that way it's a win
no way I would first of all if they pass
and I cash in so it's like a win-win for
both of us
let them let them die and let me fill my
bank account the money
you'd keep the hundred thousand dollars
if Chris Rock guys insults Drew at an
award show how do you respond to that
I'm I'm sure I would do nothing but
uh actually laugh while the camera's on
me and then be mortified when I go home
right all right number two what do you
do with the academy yeah take her hand
uh yeah I just lean over and check in
with her and see how she's feeling
number three if the joke was funny I'd
laugh but if it's just an insult uh I
wouldn't go up and slap him that's kind
of uh embarrassing for her but uh I
definitely would let Chris Rock know
with a Stern eye contact that uh he and
I now have problems number four I would
walk up to the stage and make him
apologize
no violence just with words I would say
apologize now or else let me tell you or
else
I would tickle him
Drew let me ask you at this point in the
dating game are you starting to feel a
connection toward one of the guys
oh I mean you can look at my dating
track record I've gone for the funny
person I've gone for whoever said it was
Bachelor number two when he said I would
I would take her hand I almost burst
into tears I'm not kidding do you know
how [ __ ] long it's been since
someone's taken my hand and I felt safe
with them like that is the metaphor for
life if some [ __ ] show is happening in
front of you and you can make each other
feel like it's you two against the world
and you're safe thank you Bachelor
number two may all women and men out
there protect each other more
foreign